Student Hu asks about the complexities that are involved in the PageRank algorithm
that you went over in unit six is how similar is this to what Google does
or other search engines when they are ranking pages.
So this is a good question. So the PageRank algorithm
that we described in unit six is exactly what Google started with
and this was the research paper that Larry Page and colleagues wrote
about how they would improve search ranking
and that’s exactly the algorithm that we implemented in unit six
and that was what Google was doing in its early days.
Things are a lot more complicated today
and a lot of the reason for that is well, sites adapt.
And you’d remember Anna Patterson was taking about how sites adapted
to the way AltaVista was ranking by putting lots of copies of the same word
on the page to try to show up top in the rankings
and this started to make the results less useful.
Sites have also adapted to PageRank by trying to find ways to get links to the page,
have their own pages linked to their own other pages that look different to Google,
making it so there are lots of in links and trying to make it
so you get a high rank in the page
and there is entire consultants whose business is try to find ways
to get your page higher ranked in Google.
So that means that for PageRank to continue to work,
well they have to take into account more things, so they look at things like
how things appear on the page, they look at other context,
they look at other information, not just the link structure.
But that’s still the basis for a lot of – the ranking of the pages is the link structure.
And you can see evidence of PageRank on kind of what the search results you get
when you are using Google, it’s very, very common that Wikipedia
is one of the top three results on almost anything you search for
and that’s because a lot of people link to Wikipedia
because it has got authority but also that Wikipedia links to itself a lot.
That kind of a structure helps.
Yeah, hundreds of pages link to other higher pages.
And it’s also that content of the pages is also high quality
and there is things that Google is trying to do to measure the quality of pages as well.
Yes.